Grace where are you you're making a huge
mistake
are you Karen
well Peter Paul and Mary you are
fabulous
thank you
who are you
I'm Jack Jack
oh Wheels Jack well hello honey we've
talked on the phone a million times I
can't believe we've never met
look at Chewie little hottie stand up
oh come on
look at you you are a rocket ship oh out
of here are you a strange person this is
what is this
P.S loving the boobs
perky with all kinds of attitude
Starbucks
right ah God I had no idea you would be
so
kitten with a whip
come on let's touch stomachs
oh my Lord you are a complete freak
[Applause]
oh look care stands well do you have a
well anyway honey why do I need a whale
I'm gonna live forever that is the deal
isn't it ran
I care would you sure but you don't even
know that's great but if I told you come
on let's get started
come on try give me that give me that
give me that I love it
hi my name is Karen Walker
[Applause]
oh my God that voice is ridiculous
oh
[Music]
fun
even though one could never put a price
on the pain and suffering this has
caused me
one has
Jack I don't read I'm read too
very well
item one five hundred thousand dollars
paid to me by you over the next four
years preferably in 50s
item two a Shetland pony dyed powder
blue to match my eyes
[Laughter]
three
powder blue eyes
wait Blanche I'm still on item one five
hundred thousand and fifties I've always
been turned on by one Benji Franklin
he wasn't afraid to wear his hair up and
away from the face
Franklin's on the hundred you Mook and
where do you get off asking me for 500k
do you know how many
had oh my God
[Applause]
well we did have a contract I gave you a
year of my life so Rosario could stay in
the country I don't think a trust fund
and a Corvette is too much to ask for
are you kidding me with this I plucked
you out of a 4x4 Hubble above a blinking
light in Times Square and put you in a
6x6 Maids Quarters on Park Avenue and
this is
[Music]
hey you got something out of this too
Missy who read Valley of the Dolls to
your kids every night
ha
who distracted stand for you on oyster
Tuesdays
me it was me now I got my 500 thousand
fifties fifties with Ben Franklin on
them
you know you should think very carefully
about what you're asking for Miss girly
Brown
you got a good thing going here and if
you think that you can just shamelessly
siphon cash off of a loved one like I'm
doing with my husband you've got another
thing coming
I want my money you ain't getting 88
cents for me Bros
very well I will see you in court
by the way your boobs look great today
jean-clock she's coming from Paris
yesterday now get out of here
oh hey I've got an idea I'm going to the
Barney Style with Rosario this weekend
why don't you just come along
well
I'll need a little money from the ATM
denied denied approved
thank you
maybe this was a bad idea I mean this
doesn't even look like a movie set
I told you mine
I'm on the set of my new movie poorly
decorated crack house
[Applause]
Jimmy is fun
check it out Jackie the dude the
diamonds and the dough
buddy you're
seriously you're shallow and you're a
common that's why we're so much
hello I could totally Play Straight
oh
honey
no one in the world would believe you
are straight
your purse on Tony Knight
come on fell out of the gay tree heading
every gay branch on the way down
a gay guy
it did him
no honey your gayness can be seen from
space oh you're so gay
and boy you've been eating your own
trailer the word is maitre d
uh that's not a gay word of a roller
disco
HD
m a
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh excuse me use me waiter
I would like some tea
i t wait a minute carry those almost on
like ladders
I'm sorry hack number 12 you're gonna
have to leave
m-a-i-t put your paws off of me
you are m-a-i-t-r
[Music]
un
would you keep her out of here
and in a catastrophe
Karen this isn't something you couldn't
run away from it's not like a hotel bill
or a crying baby
poor people who dream their whole lives
of a meal like this
honey I know what we should do
let's take a picture of us eating and
show it to them
wow Karen you are like a female Jesus
you're too tired to slap you bash your
face against my palm which
Jackie look at me on Fox trotting
hardly
look some people born to dance you were
born to drink
if you could cut a rug like you left a
mug I'd have something to work with
[Applause]
you're being like this
just like our friendship this dance
lesson as we know it is over
oh Shaggy
that's what you're upset about
Stan you love finny but why do things
have to change between us
[Music]
laughs
foreign